hi I'm Dez I'm from Australia hi I'm
Joyce and I'm from the United States and
today we are going to be comparing and
swapping Australian and American snacks
I'm really trying to go down under and
see what y'all got I love Australian
snacks
and I'm not just talking about Tim Tams
speaking of Tim Tams
we have them right here oh my god these
are Tim Tams and they're amazing it's
anything to do with chocolate it's
always yeah that's so true I would say
Tim Tams are the best thing Australia
has to offer that and Chris Hemsworth
hmm this tastes like a non minty thinman
delicious I love him so so web it's very
unfortunate that we have to follow up to
in terms with strawberry pop-tart sushi
Wow and the warm the way a pop-tart
should be my sister was obsessed with
these so she never let me have any
because she'd eat it all by the time we
got home yep tough luck a pancake who
like cherry or something and I thinking
what the time when you were young and
you just got back from the playground
I'm like so confused by it I think I'm
done now
I respect your opinion but I disagree
with you a thousand percent by which you
prefer pop-tarts that's like my new home
of the month this is like my husband Tim
Tams no doubt no doubt
okay so these are little hugs
I remember getting this in like
kindergarten elementary school like
we're really bringing it back actually
seen these in a long-ass time this color
is definitely not found in nature but I
don't know what you want to call it but
like generic blue is just ma
delicious I can't even open these I
swear I'm gonna go once like it I'm just
gonna open this Mindy I don't drink
whoa that's like your sugar yeah oh my
god I need to make Joe Australia just
like I expected no I'm a big fan of that
cuz that reminds me medicine and as yes
I like that would be cool time it's
happy s it tastes like Timmy time my
parents used to catch me in real but not
like drinking it and the bottle
Australia's yeah um have you ever had
cordial before okay no this also looks
like something you would pour down your
drain if it gets clogged why is what
this packaging Australia if I saw this
I'd wash my dishes with this if you went
to like a friend's house and they had
like pre-made cordial like in the fridge
it was like Jack PUD I mean I can
literally see the chemicals swirling so
I think you might have gotten the right
oh no we're going more do you need to
give it a little well that was a great
tell us well it's like it's like a
science experiment oh my god no you need
more what yeah it's too watery I might
as well just drink it straight from the
jar I kind of get what this is I'm
trying to think of the American
equivalent oh that's not bad I mean the
swirling chemicals as I take a sip is a
little bit disconcerting but show you've
drank worse things
[Music]
so the Cory old is before you I'm the
sugar level in my personal life looks
like Cookie Monster's pest like I want
that tink oh my god
okay so these I love no does but tons of
a caveat
these are just like in your teeth okay
these were my favorite when we would go
to the movie theater where you pay for
one ticket in a little time to find
those showings we don't do that anymore
government calorie-burning - wait is
this Chuck bone yes
but love yeah well we've got puns yeah
okay like sorry good - lazy but uh but I
appreciate it oh my god this is so huge
I gotta leave mom so these are roll-ups
and this is like definitely a primary
school snack that I was anot allowed to
have I could have like tiny titties like
[Applause]
this was in your lunchbox like hectic
you know I mean oh my god there would be
ones with tattoos on and you would trust
it ya know ya gonna love that
I think so yeah I've never done this
before but I'm feeling inspired okay
watch that okay yep yeah I'm not gonna
do that
Wow
intense it's really good I'll try it oh
my god I literally like I forgot that
these existed
I didn't even know how to eat it how do
you eat it like this oh my god that's so
satisfying I didn't like wide open it up
and do it again
I dare to gushes been together you can
you create like a hybrid monster mmm
gosh is it better though shoes are
better I'm happy you have some great
pics yeah finally American candy is like
intense but ultimately better Australia
had some heads you know it's like they
were solid
but the gushy is the monk does those
still say nope does this so good but
like apartments unsynced um America
Australia times are tough in the world
is is at stake right now
and to come together as one I think we
need to consider a bipartisan agreement
where the u.s. sends off gushers and
Australia sends as Tim Tams and
international relations will be improved
greatly
[Music]